[How did you find the job
that you currently have?]
This is, actually, I think the way
things are going to be:
"I didn't find it, I created it."
I created the job that I currently have.
And I think that's going to happen
a lot in the future, too.
As a matter of fact, I think people
are going to have multiple jobs.
They'll have jobs
that they're passionate about,
others that pay the bills, I think.
I think that's a really good way to go,
because you'll always have
something going on,
you're always excited about something,
there's a lot more change in your life;
it makes it more interesting.
So that would be my answer to that.
Voice-over: Click any
of these fortune cookies
to see your questions
and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie
to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie
to suggest alternative questions,
participants or career paths
for future videos.